If acceptance speeches have taught us anything,
the number one person most actors want to
please is their mom. But what happens if
they're in something a little too risquéor violent?
With that in mind, here are the
roles that got actors in trouble with their moms.
Since 2016's Captain America: Civil War, Tom
Holland has been best known as Spider-Man,
probably the most earnest and innocent superhero
in the MCU. But as much as he's enjoyed playing
the iconic web-slinger, he's also attempted
to branch out into a broader range of roles.
And the 2021 crime drama Cherry
couldn't be more of a contrast,
much to his mom's horror. Holland plays the
title character, a veteran of the Iraq War
who self-medicates his PTSD with heroin and
ends up robbing banks to fund his drug habit.
During filming, the actor sent his mother a
video of an especially grueling scene in which
his character is going through withdrawal on the
floor of a prison cell. As he recalled to Esquire,
"Biggest mistake ever [...]
She was furious with me."
Holland realized a little too
late that what his mom likes
about his movies are the parts that make her go:
"That's my little boy."
Alas, Cherry doesn't have anything
like that. Holland considers the film
the hardest role of his career, and the
same can be said for his mom. Luckily,
she eventually came around, as his parents were
able to enjoy it and be proud of their son.
Most parents would probably struggle to watch
their kids playing a character who gets brutally
tortured and killed on screen. But watching them
carry out the torturing and killing themselves
can also provoke some strong emotions. Kathy
Bates has become a TV legend in recent years
thanks to her American Horror Story performances.
But before she was torturing enslaved people in
Coven or terrifying the residents of Outpost 3 in
Apocalypse, she played obsessed fan Annie Wilkes
in the Stephen King adaptation Misery. In the
movie, Annie traps Paul Sheldon, her favorite
author, in her house and forces him to write
a new book the way that she wants it to go.
Even if you've never seen the movie or read
the novel it's based on, you probably know
about the most notorious scene in which Annie
breaks Paul's ankles with a sledgehammer.
Annie is widely considered one of the
greatest movie villains of all time,
and Bates even won an Oscar for her performance.
But her mother wasn't exactly on board. As
she revealed on an episode of Conan in 2017,
"She saw it, and she said she didn't
know what all the fuss was about,
that she had actually seen that
behavior while I was growing up."
"She just thought you were playing yourself!"
“That's exactly right, so…
moms! What can I tell ya?"
"Oh, she used to hobble everybody!"
"Yeah."
Better hide your sledgehammers next
time Kathy Bates comes to visit!
Many Zac Efron fans were disturbed to hear
that he would be playing serial killer Ted
Bundy in the 2019 biopic Extremely Wicked,
Shockingly Evil and Vile. The role was quite
the departure for the Disney star-turned-comedy
lead. And during a screening of the film,
Efron's mom couldn't get her head around it
either. As the actor recounted to Page Six,
"I’ve never seen my mom like that before.
She was so scared, she was terrified."
Efron's mom's reaction actually made him
curious about Bundy, whom he described as:
"The most notorious, evil,
scumbag killer of women."
Efron's mom also had opinions about
one of his more lighthearted roles.
In the 2016 comedy sequel Neighbors
2: Sorority Rising, his character,
coincidentally also named Teddy, distracts a
party full of sorority girls with a dance that
ends with him revealing his private parts,
although it was actually a prosthetic prop.
A paparazzi picture from the set made its way
to Efron's mom, who ended up telling her son,
"Have some class!"
There are two schools of thought regarding Robert
Downey Jr.'s performance in the 2008 satire Tropic
Thunder. One says that the blackface the white
actor donned to play a white actor who's undergone
cosmetic surgery to darken his skin is a hilarious
commentary on the ridiculousness of actors who
change their appearance for a role. The other
says that ultimately, Downey was still a white
actor in blackface playing into stereotypes about
Black men. Downey's mom was in the second camp.
During a 2020 appearance on The Joe Rogan
Experience podcast, the actor admitted,
"My mother was horrified."
As he recalled, she told him,
"I have a bad feeling about this."
"I was like, 'Yeah, me too, Mom.'”
Downey also explained his decision to take the
role despite his mother's warning, as he noted,
"I get to hold up to nature the
insane self-involved hypocrisy
of artists and what they think
they’re allowed to do on occasion."
He also added,
"It was impossible to not have it be
an offensive nightmare of a movie,
and 90 percent of my Black friends
are like, 'Dude, that was great.'"
Jonah Hill's filmography doesn't exactly
scream "family-friendly." Movies like Superbad,
Knocked Up, and Get Him to the Greek definitely
aren't exactly safe for watching with your mom.
But in 2011, he proved that he could carry a
dramatic role that his parents would have no
trouble watching when he picked up an Oscar
nomination for the baseball flick Moneyball.
Then in 2013, he combined his Oscar-worthy
dramatic skills with his comedy background for the
crime epic The Wolf of Wall Street, in which he
played a financial trader who made Hill's previous
characters look like well-behaved kindergartners.
The actor struggled to find anything to like
about the goldfish-eating delinquent, so
perhaps it's no surprise that watching it
with his mom wasn't exactly the best idea. As
he recounted on Late Night with Seth Meyers,
"[My mom] sat next to me at the
Wolf of Wall Street premiere,
and it's all fun and games until you pull
your d--- out of your pants. She's like,
'Alright, you know, I think I've
got enough of your body of work.'"
"At least that part of your body."
"Exactly."
Hill was actually wearing
a prosthetic private part,
but that didn't exactly cover up the awkwardness.
If you only know Aubrey Plaza as the deadpan but
surprisingly sincere April Ludgate on Parks and
Recreation, watching her movies might come as a
bit of a shock to you. She tends to pick projects
that are of a piece with April's misanthropic
outsider tendencies, but much more extreme.
She played a wannabe time traveler in the
sci-fi comedy Safety Not Guaranteed, a zombie
in Life After Beth, a sadistic nun in The Little
Hours, and an aspiring influencer-slash-stalker
in Ingrid Goes West. She even got busy
with Robert De Niro in Dirty Grandpa!
But it was the 2020 psychological
thriller Black Bear that truly proved
to be too much for Plaza's family
to bear. In the mind-bending film,
she plays an actress on the edge of a breakdown
due to her director husband's emotional abuse.
But it wasn't the dark plot that worried
her family so much as the tough production
conditions. When she was interviewed
by Adam Sandler for Interview Magazine,
she revealed that the shoot was difficult and
involved a lot of nights. As she described it,
"We were living in these weird cabins
in the middle of nowhere [...] The
lines started to get blurred toward the
end because we shot it chronologically,
and I started to not really know what was
real or not. I really fell apart afterwards."
Her family was understandably worried about
her because she wasn't her typical self.
Her parents did eventually see the movie,
although her mom was apparently horrified.
"I'm in a very vulnerable position in the
movie, and it's excruc- it's painful to watch."
In 1989, Julia Roberts was best
known for making moviegoers cry
in her Oscar-nominated role as Shelby in Steel
Magnolias. Soon thereafter, she graduated to
leading lady status by taking the iconic part
of sex worker Vivian in 1990's Pretty Woman.
Roberts won over audiences and
Richard Gere's corporate raider Edward
with her bathtub karaoke, legendary
comeback to a snooty sales assistant,
and combination of toughness and vulnerability.
But none of that changed the fact that she was
worried about what her mom would think.
As she explained to Rolling Stone,
"My mom works for the Catholic archdiocese of
Atlanta [...] I mean, my mom's boss baptized me."
Hoping to avoid the inevitable,
Roberts tried evasive maneuvers by
calling her mom at work and telling her,
"Hi, mom, I got a job [...] It's a Disney
movie! I've got to go, talk to you later.'"
Pretty Woman was released by Buena Vista Pictures,
Disney's former film distribution studio, so she
technically wasn't lying. And hopefully the Best
Lead Actress Oscar nomination she eventually got
for the movie helped smooth things over as well.
The 2012 film Flight should probably never be
watched by anyone who's ever felt the tiniest
sliver of fear of flying. It stars Denzel
Washington as pilot Whip Whitaker, who averts
a plane crash by rolling the jet, even though he
was under the influence of drugs and alcohol at
the time. Most of the passengers and crew survive,
but not Katerina, the flight attendant played by
Nadine Velazquez. It couldn't have been easy for
the actress' parents to watch their daughter's
character die, but that's not why she waited until
a month before the movie came out to tell them
about it. As it turns out, she was more worried
about what they would think of the explicit scene
of Katerina and Whip spending the night together.
As she explained to the Chicago Tribune,
"I knew they wouldn't have understood.
I would have felt guilty doing it had
I [told them] when I got the offer.
So I just waited until it was done."
Her parents' responses ended up being
what she'd expected. As she recalled,
"My mom was horrified for about five seconds.
And my dad in the background
was like, 'No, you didn't.'"
Since the scene in question happens
within the first ten minutes,
she advised them to just show up late.
A movie about rival ballerinas that comes out
during the holiday season and stars a Harvard
graduate might sound on paper like a mom-friendly
choice for a family trip to the movies.
But 2010's Black Swan is less about the dancing
and more about the terrifying psychological toll
of a highly competitive athletic profession,
which is why Mila Kunis' mom was wary of her
daughter's part in the film. The actress lost
a significant amount of weight for the part,
to the point that her mom was legitimately
worried about her. As Kunis recalled to E!,
"My mom freaked out. Everybody
started panicking. She was like,
'You have to promise me this isn't going to
affect you.' I was like, 'I promise it won't,
but it might take me a little time to be
okay with having a little more fat on me.'"
The experience opened Kunis' eyes to the movie
industry's unhealthy concept of what makes for
a good-looking body. Fortunately, though,
she managed to keep her promise to her mom,
as it took her a mere five days to gain
back the 20 pounds that she'd lost.
If you're an actor with parents who
are also actors, that doesn't mean
they're going to automatically be
happy with all the roles you choose,
as Dakota Johnson has discovered. Her parents
are Melanie Griffith and Don Johnson, who both
have their own experience with taking their
clothes off on screen. But when Dakota landed
the coveted lead role in the Fifty Shades of Grey
trilogy, her mom couldn't bring herself to watch.
When mother and daughter were on the
red carpet together at the 2015 Oscars,
ABC's Lara Spencer asked Griffith if she would
see Fifty Shades of Grey, to which she replied,
"I don't think I can. I
think it would be strange."
Dakota said that it was fine that
her mom didn't want to watch it,
but she still held out some hope
that she would change her mind.
When Spencer assured Griffith that her
daughter was very good in the movie,
Griffith said that she didn't need to watch
it to know that, to which Dakota responded,
"All right! You don't have to see it!"
Griffith apparently kept her word, at least for
a few more years. In 2018, Dakota told Hello!
Magazine that neither of her parents had seen
any of the Fifty Shades movies, as she explained,
"It's inappropriate for them.
But they're okay about it."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.